good morning everybody from the sunny
sydney today my name is abraham singh
and i'm from the hawksville
institute for the environment at western
sydney university
today i'm going to talk to you about
microbiome and plant health and how that
can be harnessed to increase the
agriculture and plant productivity
before i go into the presentations i
would like to acknowledge
some of our co-authors emanuel delgado
baccarizo
is from the spain pancreas through ready
from the core iowa state university
in usa and elio nora gidi uh from
the hawksville institute in western city
university
the presentations today is about
microbiome and how that can improve
the crop productivity let's remind
ourselves first
the key function of the soil so crop
productivity is
one of the key functions that soil
provides
and provides and through the nutrient
cycling
reservoir for the plant nutrients
enhancing biological activities and so
on
but the other key functions that
includes the filtrations and buffering
the water
which ensure the drinking water for the
human population and other
animals but also the water for the
irrigations
and other other recreational purposes
soil functions includes one of the key
functions includes the climate
regulations
through the uh and the mitigations
of the greenhouse gas emissions and all
these functions
are carried out mainly by the soil
microbes
other organisms does in fact in terms of
for example
the soil animals impact those processes
through the feeding and pre and predator
relationship
with the microbes but the microbes are
the main energy
carried out those functions
agriculture is the topic of discussions
today
and as we all know we have a huge
challenges
to increase the food productions from
the existing land by 50
by 2050 to feed the growing
human populations and in reality the
farm productivity has been a structural
decline since
middle 1990s particularly in the
developed countries what does it means
the additions of more fertilizers and
resources
and plant breeding pro plant breeding
programs does not increase the
proportionally
the yield of the crops there is
agriculture
is now being asked to contribute towards
the climate change mitigations
there has been significant pressures
because of the agricultural productivity
because of efficacy loss of
agrochemicals and plant breeding program
there is a negative impact of those
conventional farming for example the use
of pesticides
on the food quality and human health and
there is
a consumer demand for the quality not
only the quality of food which have a
less
chemical residues but also to contribute
towards
the environmental protections
and if you look at these are the
significant challenges and if you look
at
all those significant analysis that is
carried out by the different people
across the world this is a slides come
from one of my colleagues in
chinese agriculture university in
beijing for surjan
where the what is the look at is what
are
the sustainable farming approaches that
can increase that productivity
and if you one of the things is that if
we can increase the soil fertility or
soil health
we can achieve 15 to 20 percent of the
increased productivity
without further increasing the chemical
inputs in our systems
and if you combine that ingredients
while health
with the efficient plant varieties ratio
and varieties
we can achieve up to 50 percent of the
the
the 50 of increase in the productivity
which is a minimum requirement and in
both these cases
the microbiomes play a critical role
to achieve those goals
but there's other factors that also rise
the agriculture's
uh agriculture and soil microbiome that
is industry itself
if you look at the microbiome industry
globally that includes all aspects it's
almost a trillion dollar
that does not include the pharmaceutical
industries as you know
more a lot of pharmaceutical products
particularly the antibiotics comes from
the microbial origins
agriculture product itself today counts
between five to six million
u.s dollars market value of that bio
pesticides
is one of the fastest growing of their
own four billion dollars
and if you look at how this industry is
performing
it is expected to increase to 72 sorry
12 billions
by 2016 2026 sorry and its global market
is increasing at the rate
3.5 times faster than the chemical
pesticides
so it is one of the fastest growing
market
in in the globally in the uh in terms of
the agricultural purposes
what i'm going to talk today i've
divided my discussion in three different
uh short presentations one is the driver
and the distribution of soil microbial
diversities
and then second we'll talk about the
plant microbiome and how that's
contributes
towards the sustainable increase in the
farm productivity
and the third which i will mainly talk
about the global initiatives that we
have established
to identify the rule and the
role of the crop microbial in the
sustainable agriculture
the first one is the distributions of
the microbial communities
obviously i will not go into details of
those
um issues the because of the constraint
of the time
but let's start with one of the work we
are very interested is the dominant
species
our interests always have been the
to learn from the other branches of the
sciences life sciences for example
animal ecology plant ecology where we
have a lot of
uh informations of the driver and
distribution of the plant
communities for example and one of the
things we
if you see that there is a hundreds of
thousands to millions of
species of plant and animals but only
few
species really globally dominates
and one of the other hypothesis was
if the ecological questions is
ecological ecological cherry is
um valid for the plant
it should be valid for the microbial
communities and so that
is there is a dominant microbial taxa
that's are that that's are globally
distributed
and what are their drivers to test that
we sample across the globes in 237 sites
and we measure a number of climatic
properties but also soil microbial
communities both through the amplicon
sequencing
and the high throughput short
consequences
and what we found is that just like a
plant in animals there are dominant
taxes and how did we
define the dominant taxes that's a
constituted
10 among the 10 percent of the relative
abundance
and present and is ubiquitously present
and and we define
ibiquity by the presence of the
seventy-five percent of the samples
and we did find there was a two percent
of the taxa which accounts for five
five hundred eleven phylotypes of
bacteria
that are fit the definition of the
dominant taxa
but if you look at the relative
amendments these are only two percent of
the number of of taxa but it counts for
41 percent of the relative evidence
in their global distribution
we then went on and looked for the soil
fungi
another critical micro microbial
communities of uh
for the soil function side of things
they accounted
in fact the dominant taxa only account
for 0.1 percent in terms of the number
of the total taxa
but again it's accounted for 18 percent
of the relative evidence in in their
global distributions
and when then we will be able to use
these informations to predict the
distribution of the structure
across the globe where you will expect
them to dominate where you
expect them to be the rare and and so we
able to uh predict that and make a
global map
of these structures uh to be present
so somebody can questions what is
why we need to know the distribution of
microbial communities although a
dominant texture
it's a critical because first things we
focus on the dominant taxa it reduces
the number of the
species we should be focusing because if
the mass
and mass functions have a hypothesis
hypothesis
is true then these taxes play a very
dominant role in the ecosystem functions
but another things that we can predict
the the economically
important attacks as distribution in
this slides as you can see
we use those um again the global survey
to look at the current distribution of
the soil bond fungal pathogens here we
are talking about the crop pathogens and
the plant pathogens
and we look at what are their
distributions and when they will look at
that
what sort of environmental conditions
they prefer
and then we able to predict on the in
the middle of that is the predictions
what will happen in 2035
and and beyond the distributions of
these soil board fungal pathways and you
see there's a dramatic increases
in their in their evidence relative
amendments
obviously this is a predictions that
comes with some uncertainty
and people can question this is
prediction so we then
go on to verify this productions with
the real
time data where we sample 10 year old
climate change experiments
to look at the the changes in the
evidence of those taxa
in the in the warming treatment and that
is on your right side
of your data which support that our
predictions
are are appropriate
the other critical rule of
our work have been linking those
microbial community
microbial diversity ecosystem functions
and because
without linking to that relationship
the loss or the manage or any policy
development either the management policy
or the conservation policy we need to
demonstrate that if we lose some
bacterial texture
or if you changes the the microbial
community you have an impact on the
ecosystem functions
here we again took two uh
site of things one is a global drawing
so we sampled across the global dryland
as you know it accounts for a 41 of
global lands
and and and and and then another sites
we sample is just into our escort land
and we choose in those two sides for the
reasons the difference reason
is that these sites are really
contrasting again
if there is a relationship between the
biodiversity ecosystem functions
it should hold into two different two
contrasting ecosystem types
and this was our real hypothesis and
in this uh slides as you can see
that we what we the word we use the
ecosystem multi-functionality on the
bottom of both those
uh graph that is
the averaging of the multiple ecosystem
function that was measured that was
including plant productivity
the nutrient cycling availability of
nutrients and so on and then you
average that and what do you say that in
both these cases
in both this contrasting site microbial
diversity
has a direct impact
on the ecosystem functions and which is
account for the unique
variations within that ecosystem
functions so that is
evidence that if you lose the microbial
diversity
you will lose the ecosystem functions
proportionally
the second part of my presentation is
the agriculture microbiome
and how that's impacting plant
productivity and
sustainable development goals the
agriculture's
microbiomes is a critical um i will come
in that
in a minute but and it's it's
can be used to increase the farm
productivity
and that then contributes in number of
the
the sustainable development goals
including zero hunger
and good health and well-being clean
water and sanitations i'm not going to
go into that details because
we have discussed that in more detail in
publication which is cited below
why plant microbiome is important just
like the human microbiome
plant microbiomes plays a critical role
in all aspects of plant physiology and
health
for example it ensure that
nutrient availability it ensure the
access of the plants to those nutrients
and the water
it it's play an important role
in priming the plant immune system just
like human gut microbiome play
role in human immune systems the plant
microbiomes have the same rule
it also plays an important role through
the productions of number of
metabolites that impacts the plant
physiology immune systems
but also act as antimicrobials
against the pathogen and so on
plant microbiome just like human
microbiomes
um are are selective it's not like
most of the plant microbiomes comes from
the soil some also come from the seeds
and other
other parental transplants but mostly
come from the soil
but it is not that any soil microbes
can enter into the plant disease this is
one of the example that the plant
filters
those microbes and and only
fuel which able to colonize insights
can get into so the factors that really
impact is a plant-as-specific filtration
that is driven by the genetics and the
immune system of the plant
mutual recognitions by the plant and
microbes
the microbial traits not all microbes
have the capacity to enter
and colonize the internal tissues and
then also the presence and the
opportunities
just like the human microbiome
the if you look at that because of that
intimate relationship between plant and
microbiome
there has been a a lot of focus just
like human microbiome to produce a
product
that in fact there is as you know
there's a lot of product in the markets
that's that increases the plant
performance
and and the productivity but there is
other factors that
also driving this translational
agriculture microbiome
it's a policy top down you have seen the
the european union green deal that's
demands rejection of 50 of chemical
pesticide replaced by the balance
intelligence
by 2030 and there's a consumer demand
for the chemical free or less chemical
chemically chemically residues
food product there is a significant
increase in investments both by the
establishment in a startup company and
as you see that
as i said the market is going remarkably
high this almost 17
per year and there's an enormous
opportunity in this area
because if you look at the human
medicine pharmaceuticals 50
of our medicines come from the natural
issues
in that case of pesticides is only
called further 11 percent
so there's a huge amount of resources
naturally that are still to be
discovered and translated
into the products
and that's the driver of the microwave
industry as you know the old microbiome
industry the fastest growing
starts up in agriculture microbiome is
one of them
and because it's fulfill a number of
issues from
plant productivity environmental
sustainability
it ensures the resource is food
securities
but also the quality of source and so it
impacts
in terms of low chemical food but also
the nutrients dense food
and that's then directly benefits the
human
and environmental health but
in my opinion there is a huge
opportunity not just 17 percent this
industry is a poise to take off
um commercially if we
addresses some of the key technical
challenges
and these technical challenges includes
the inconsistent field efficacy
so what happens you use one product it
works in one field but it does not work
the same way in other fields
there is a lack of product diversity so
there is if you look at that there is a
few species that you can use
mainly basalis receptor masses and so on
and
that are in the market
the sustaining the activity of microbes
in the formulations and then you put in
the fills
is a real constraint and the other
factor can also
influence activities and one of the
things we are not going to discuss today
more detail is there is some genuine
product in the market but there is some
snack oils
and we need to differentiate that for
the industry to grow
and we believe these technical
challenges can be
solved by addressing some of the
fundamental
and applies knowledge gaps and the
fundamental knowledge
we still have a limited understanding
of the ecological and evolutionary
process
that determines the microbiome assembly
of the plants
we have no idea what is what does the
healthy plant microbiome looks like
the same as in is in case of the human
microbiome
we need to distinguish the correlations
from the calculations
and then we need to go beyond the
bacterial communities
and look for the fungi and viral
community
that how they get assembled and what
will they play
in the uh the plant performance but
there's other critical
knowledge gaps in the applied and
applied and translational size
as we know there's a lot of product in
the market and the one of the things is
that we use the
develop the products and throw in all
sort of environmental conditions
but we have a little understanding the
ecological requirement of those
introduced micro flora to colonize and
express its phenotype
we have a very little understanding on
the interplay between the
introduced microbiota or the products
with the host genetics
and immune systems we also have a less
uh identity uh less knowledge on the
identity of the first set of microbiota
that respond to a stress and in
technological sites
we have a less ability to manipulate
microbiome of natural microbiome in situ
in a way in a rationally rationally
so that we activate the activities of
the beneficial microbials
i believe the solutions to these
challenges lies
to focus on the system-based approach
including the predator and relationship
so all soil
soil bacteria plant soil bacteria fungi
virus but also the small animals in
pre-pre-entry due to relationship
we need to target a keystone core
microbiota
the core microbiota we define in in the
next slides
as a as we need to assume these products
are
comfortable with the host and its
microbiota
we need to have a multi-disciplinary
approach with a long-term vision rather
than the short-term outcomes
so it will take turns to understand the
sciences
and then the develop the tools and
further
the implications public private
partnership
is essential from the inception of the
ideas
to make sure there is a commercial
outcome and global
coordinated global approach is needed to
improve their outcomes
i said that's one of the idea is to
define
the develop the product from the crop
microbiome or at least the compatible
with the crop microbiome what is a crop
sorry prop core microbiome
core microbiomes are the microbiome that
is
present in the that particular plant
species
irrespective of the environmental
conditions
irrespective of the climatic conditions
irrespective of
the the the management practices under
and it is considered at some level these
are the uh
there is eco ecological and evolution
relationship
between those microbes and this plant
community
it is a subset of the the
whole plant microbial this is one
example i'm giving you that we completed
in the sugarcane
which is a national survey which is 1600
kilometer radius sampling
and what we found is that there is a
0.2 of the total bacterial taxes
is is what we call is the core
microbiota
a microbiome of the species but if you
look their
dominance is only account for two point
zero point two percent
in terms of the species number or or the
taxon number
but this relative abundance in the plant
is a 35 percent
in fungi the core microbiota
a microbiome accounted only from 1.7
percent of the total taxa
but it accounted for the 71 percent of
relative abundance
and so they are the dominant species and
ubiquitous species
in the plant communities and then the
second what i use the hub microbiota
so we use the cystical co-occurrence
analysis to look at the microbiota
that's at least assistively tell us
they are central to the community so
these
microbiota are linked to other
microbiota
by multiple linkages and so the theory
is
that if you remove those one of those
microbiota
then the community assembly will
um collapse but that is a physical
relation
evidence where is the empirical evidence
for this study what we
did we knock out two basilisk species
from these 12
so microbiota half microbiota using
antibiotics
you not only see there is a collapse of
the assembly
there's a huge impact on the
plant productivity there was a 50
decline
in the plant productivity due to due to
removal of those
two half taxa saying that these species
are not there just because the
statistical
reason they are perform a critical host
functions
and if you remove those microbiota
the host functions will be compromised
there's another angle to look at the
microbiota is not all microbiota have a
direct impact i'm not going to go in
detail of this my
uh slides just to summarize that
we in the wheat and there is a
disease very devastating disease called
crown raw disease caused by the
figerium pseudogram energy and
if if the plants is uh
gets infected by fijian in severe case
plant dies
what we found is that there is a
bacterial taxon in the plant called the
streptomanas
multiphilia and they recognizes physium
before
plant the wheat itself can recognize and
they
then try the plant immune system to
defend itself against the pathogen so it
the the s multi uh maltophila
act as an early warning system for the
figerium
that's then lead into the plant immune
systems what in some level
it is a key to vaccines of the human
being
so obviously these oils are very similar
to human
and plant micron there's a whole range
of
similarity between human and cut
microbiota
in terms of the role they play in the
nutritional roles the physiological role
role in terms of the reproduction
influence the reproductions rate and so
on
but the problem is um that for the
human microbiome we have very good
understanding of
some of the aspects of human microbiome
there have been billions of dollars
invested in this area
over the last two decades but compared
to that our understanding of the plant
microbiome
is limited and that's in my opinion
is what's driving the inconsistency of
the product
in different environmental conditions
the fundamental understandings
to do that we have established what is
called the global initiatives of the
crop microbiome and sustainable
agriculture
you can see there is a the white page
link provided in the slides so we are
welcome you all
to come and visit these sites the aim of
these initiatives
is to identify the crops core and hub
microbiota we discussed couple of slides
before
identify the processes through which
crop microbiome
and assembly takes place for example the
digestive
filtering what contributions plant
microbiome
plays in the disease suppressions and
the resource use efficiency
what are the relative contributions of
microbiomes
in the yield of or the farm yields and
farm productivity
and what are the microbial indicator of
the farm productivity and sustainability
so these are the short-term delivers of
this initiative
it's then contribute directly to
multiple economic and policy
outcomes some of them is just mentioned
economic growth job creation in the
regional areas
and because it will promote the regional
products
it will contribute directly to the
sustainability and biodiversity of
multiple united nations goals
it has a climate mitigation proportions
because this aims to reduces the use of
fertilizers it improved the livelihood
of the regional original part of the
world and capacity buildings
by the training within the different
global regions
so what we are doing that what is our
approach so we have target for the
initially at least the five crops the
wheat rice corn potato in the cotton
first four are the largest crops grow
worldwide
the cotton we chose we wanted to one
crop that is
not food crop but a cash crop that is
being used
again in multiple parts of the world but
essential
of of the the crops likely
for each crop we will sample 250 sites
uh so in re and we will sample two soils
which will be the uh the the bulk soils
and the plant raj of
rajasthan sauce and then we will also
samples
the plant leaf plant stalks and plant
roots
and in compared to that we will also
samples 250 sites for the natural size
which is
what we're defining is that at least
they have they have not been
in the manner active management of human
for at least 10 years
so in total we'll be sampling 300
sorry 3000 sizes sites across the globe
we already have a very good and strong
uh consortiums of the 100
150 scientific groups from across the
globe
and you can see there is a quite nicely
dis distributes
across all part of the the
the continents different parts of the
continent this is of course
this is still open we still invite any
of you
you have an interest in the club
microwave come come and join
this initiative this is about
partnership this is about collaborations
addressing the issues which goes beyond
industry in the policy
but what the ecosystem service the
biodiversity
the food securities and environmental
sustainability
we have a multiple partners um that
comes together to form these conditions
and and on the end
you see those some of those names but i
would also like
to take this opportunity to thank
kaizens for partially supporting
this activity by providing us some
reasons and dna sections and kids
with that i would like to thank you very
much for your time to listening
representation
thank you very much